Шановні колеги я прошу дуже уважно бути
особлива голову комітету з
антикорупційної політики п радину а ви
знаєте кілька років тому коли в
парламенті ми зараз приймали
антикорупційну реформу в цій залі був
тодішній президент Порошенко тодішній
уряд для того щоб разом показати єдність
всіх гілок влади щодо необхідності
прийняття цих законів для отримання
безвізу тому безвіз країна вчасно попри
війну отримала зараз зверніть увагу тут
немає президента зверніть увагу тут
немає уряду який насправді веде
переговори про
початок старту офіційних перемовин щодо
вступу України до ЄС і тут немає преси
що дуже важливо хоча ми неодноразово
європейська Солідарність наголошували на
тому що мають бути публічні ці дебати
щодо відновлення електронного
декларування і наша фракція безумовно
підтримує прозорість декларування і те
що декларації були публічними з дня
відновлення декларування це відразу хочу
сказати На жаль вчора колеги відбулася
фальсифікація засідання комітету зараз
цими нашим голосуванням ми з вами
відновимо декларування для депутаток
сільради які не можуть зараз виїхати
рішенням Зеленського за кордон дітей
провідати зате вони будуть декларуватись
не отримуючи ні копійки від держави але
ті люди які займають посади з
корупційними найвищими ризиками А це
представники наглядових рад керівники
держпідприємств представники і головне
радники порадники офісу президента вони
не декларуються Хоча вони керують
країною сьогодні в Чернігові обшуки в
ломако а виконуючий обов'язки мера міста
це вказівка офісу президента у нас
тероризують опозицію це вказівки офісу
президента корупція в офісі президента
ви знаєте коли в нас радник офісу
президента позаштатний який брав участь
в міжнародних переговорах стоїть
хизується навколо Лексуса невідомо
звідки куплено і розповідає Що він до
кінця свого життя омари буде їсти на
дачі і сміється з усіх українців він не
декларується пане Арестович і це рішення
антикорупційного комітету ви знаєте коли
пані разів нас своїми подругами Саше і
іншими стояли біля банкової з
розвішаними трусами кілька років тому
кричали постірайте ваші брудні труси то
зараз будь ласка скажіть банкові
постірати бородні труси які вони всій
країні показують коли вони займаються
корупцією ми вимагаємо перед розглядом
закону продекларування заслухати
стенограму комітету щоб ви побачили як
комітет спочатку підтримав поправку
Володя арієва щодо голосування
позаштатних радників президента а потім
після округу банкової почали це
переголосувати і сама пані Разіна в тому
числі якщо буде сфальсифікована зараз це
голосування ми будемо змушені не тільки
звертати на це увагу суспільства а й
звертатися до суду Я таких реплік у нас
прізвище трусив